samurail has quickly become one of
comedy's biggest names but it actually
took him over 15 years to get there
there's four pieces to the samurail
comedy fame formula and the first one is
that he's actually a student of comedy
when i interviewed him on this podcast
he referenced the paper being the gems
so all this work off stage of him
actually learning the craft learning how
to write a joke and
actually a lot of people may not notice
about sam he actually studied ancient
greek comedy you like did an independent
study at nyu
about it was like ancient greek comedy
yeah i liked it a lot like what did what
did that reveal to you about comedy
that it's the same themes going back
4000 bc they've always been fart jokes
there's always been dick jokes people
think it's going to be so unique but
it's like now we're all [ __ ] none of
us are that unique we all have there's
like eight different types of people
being a student
always and even after interviewing over
400 comics everyone still says
they're always still learning regardless
of 30 years in or three months in
they're always still learning so that's
a that's a big thing but
with that learning
my friends there is also executing so
there is also he's not only a student of
comedy but he is a practitioner of
comedy his early hustle was barking for
stage time
which is basically trying to hand out
flyers so people come into uh like a
venue so that you can then perform as
well there's he tells a story on the
podcast about getting spit on
while on stage and all i heard when he
got what got up was like
and i was like oh [ __ ] i knew he's gonna
spit on me oh and he tried to get to the
stage and the waitresses all liked me
there because i worked the door so they
were kind of barricading the stage and
he i just heard
and it just right on my shirt you know
and uh like terrible people have the
best aim you know but it all comes from
being on stage a lot grinding it out sam
has been doing comedy over 15 years now
but he didn't get his first late night
set until eight and a half years in so
he did a lot of grinding to get to that
point so i think a lot of comics
don't forget
you've got to get on stage you're doing
all this learning but you got to get on
stage as well the third ingredient of
this formula
collaborations last week we talked about
the impact bill burr has had on comedy
as well as other comedians all the way
back to rodney dangerfield in the 80s
putting on young comics but also think
about the collaborations you can do with
your fellow comedians you know sam has a
podcast with mark norman he had a
podcast with taylor tomlinson and they
shot skits together amy schumer
actually produced sam's first comedy
special so that's another example of a
comedian helping a comedian which is
what we're all about here so the fourth
ingredient we have he's a student of
comedy he's a practitioner of comedy
he's a collaborator but he's also a doer
he's a doer in the sense that he is
self-producing his own projects you know
he self-produced his own special
uh on his own youtube channel he
self-produced a documentary as well
that's on his own youtube channel he's
releasing content all the time he is not
just
getting complacent
with oh wait for this opportunity rx
he's out there creating it and helping
others do the same that special was so
groundbreaking that he actually ended up
on david letterman's new netflix show
getting asked by david letterman about
that comedy special and it all came from
him doing and when you see someone at
his level the amount of content he's
putting out based on his experience
level as well but also something we
referenced last week
that bill burr found steph tolev on
social media he saw a clip of her and
then ended up putting her on a couple of
these showcases that he's done
but fun fact about sam morill
he actually got his role in joker
because the director todd phillips saw
his clip of him
so there's something to
putting out quality content as we talk
about doing
do where you are a lot of times i can be
guilty of overthinking instead of doing
and i'm hoping that people watching this
start doing more i think the important
thing to remember here is like you know
this wasn't overnight for sam you know
it's over 15 years in the making of a
lot of hard work
and the big thing is just the power is
in your hands you know and i recently
heard a podcast called hidden brain and
they're talking about humor and they
said a laugh is like
it's like meditating um exercising and
having sex all at once so like the power
of laughter is
very compelling and very important so
don't take your comedy for granted but
really work at it
treat it as precious as it is and do
and by just doing it that also means
share this video if you enjoyed this
video share it on reddit facebook social
media so we can help get sam's story out
there and start finding that next great